[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de ce
mardi 27 novembre deux ministres et deux
secrétaires d'état et qu en cours
christophe castaner nicole belloubet
marlène schiappa et laurent nonies était
ce matin au commissariat de la ville
ils ont lancé un portail de signalement
des violences sexuelles et sexistes
installé dans les locaux de la police
nationale près d'un million de repas
distribués dans les yvelines la 34e
campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
s'est ouverte aujourd'hui quinze mille
bénéficiaires se rendent régulièrement
dans les 27 centres du département
reportage au sein de l'antenne de
trappes enfin dans cette édition
immersion au sein du généthon à evry en
essonne c'est le laboratoire de la
recherche génétique sur les maladies
rares elle concerne en france trois
millions de personnes
le généthon est financé à 85% par le
téléthon qui se déroule les 7 et 8
décembre prochains
on recevra d'ailleurs dans ce journal
les organisateurs du téléthon à
coignières qui revient dans la commune
après plusieurs années d'absence
à suivre également le coup de coeur
culture de la semaine dédiée au festival
à saint quentin du film documentaire qui
est organisé par tv 78 un portail à des
signalements de violences sexuelles a
donc été lancé aujourd'hui au
commissariat de guyancourt deux
ministres dont celui de l'intérieur
christophe castaner et des secrétaires
d'état étaient présents pour l'occasion
les détails avec ce sujet de mickaël el
nido ne rien laisser passer c'est le
message qu'ont voulu transmettre quatre
membres du gouvernement ce mardi matin
au commissariat de guyancourt
christophe castaner marlène schiappa
laurent lyonnaise et nicole belloubet
sont venus inaugurer un portail de
signalement des violences sexuelles et
sexistes une plateforme ouverte 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 pour qu'on
puisse libérer la parole pour au fond
réussir cette exigence continuum de
sécurité qui va de la prévention par l'
écoute l'accueil
la procédure est la sanction autant de
sujets sur lequel nous devons offrir à
chaque victime
les moyens de se faire entendre en 2010
est en france plus d'un million de
femmes ont été confrontées à une
situation de harcèlement au travail ou
dans les espaces publics
ce service gratuit et ouvert à tous aura
pour but de les dénoncer
quand vous êtes témoin d'un cambriolage
vous appelez la police ou la gendarmerie
quand vous avez connaissance d'une
violences sexistes et sexuelles votre
devoir de citoyen
c'est d'appeler la police ou la
gendarmerie où désormais de vous
connecter à cette plate forme de
signalement des violences sexistes et
sexuelles au commissariat de guyancourt
c'est ce policier un psychologue vont
veiller à traiter ces demandes au niveau
national les victimes pourront dialoguer
sous la forme d'un chat avec les agents
elle sera sur une page avec un message
automatique lui indique bonjour comment
puis-je vous aider pour qu'elles ne se
sentent pas seuls devant sa page blanche
et elle pourra alors libérer sa parole
sur sur le vécu sur des violences
sexuelles ou ou sexistes qu'elle aurait
pu voir ou non elle aurait pu être
victime est un opérateur ou une
opératrice lui répondra en cas de forte
fréquentation du chat des effectifs
supplémentaires pourraient être recrutés
dans les prochains mois
la déplacement ministériel au lendemain
d'un autre dans les yvelines hier jean
michel blanquer référent jean michel
blanquer ray prend cris esther était au
lycée condorcet de lits mais elle est
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la culture sont venus pour un autre
lancement celui de la plateforme cinéma
point lesite.tv ce dispositif permettra
aux élèves et professeurs de collèges et
lycées d'accéder à une base de données
de films du cinéma d'auteur et des
grands classiques reportage de patrick
jacques de dixmude et de manon barredo
du cinéma dans les collèges et les
lycées c'est possible grâce à la
plateforme cinéma point lesite.tv elle
sera un outil supplémentaire
d'approfondissement pour les enseignants
les deux membres du gouvernement jean
michel blanquer franck riester ont lancé
le projet ce lundi au lycée condorcet de
lit
l'éducation
à l'image et d'éducation au cinéma font
pleinement partie de l'éducation tout
coup et alors même que nos élèves sont
plongés dans des vins d'image toute la
journée par la vie que nous avons
aujourd'hui il est essentiel qu'ils
soient éduqués à une compréhension de ce
qu'il ya derrière chaque image
et puis tout simplement à la culture
parce que le cinéma c'est le septième à
la plateforme mettra à disposition une
cinquantaine de films de patrimoine
les élèves et leurs enseignants pourront
télécharger gratuitement ses films en
toute légalité
c'est surtout dans nos lycées de
banlieue j'insiste sur ce point là c'est
un vrai c'est un vrai lien social et
culturel c'est à dire qu'on est de
diverses cultures il ya différents
niveaux sociaux et ben c'est le cinéma
qui nous rassemble ce projet est porté
par france télévisions avec comme
souhait de développer la culture
cinématographique des collégiens et
lycéens
on trouve des choses assez différentes
ça va de murnau à rohmer enfin une
cinquantaine de films à terme
aujourd'hui il y en a 31 très exactement
qui sont disponibles sur la plateforme
on va continuer à l'enrichir donc voilà
c'est des films comme le dit dominique
besnehard incontournable qu'il faut
avoir vu cinéma point lesite.tv succède
à ciné lycée un dispositif équivalent
mise en place en 2010 actualités
transport en bref à présent avec le
projet eole qui rentre dans le concret
il s'agit du prolongement du rer e à
l'ouest de paris 55 km de lignes
supplémentaires jusqu'à mantes la jolie
ce lundi la sncf a lancé des travaux à
ougrée sion premier regard des yvelines
du nouveau tracé
ce chantier devrait durer un an et
demain le tunnelier d'eole fera son
baptême un tunnel de 8 km killer relire
à l'égard de haussmann saint lazare à la
défense 650 mille voyageurs devraient
profiter de ce prolongement première
rame attendu pour 2024 à coignières ce
dimanche ce sera bien un duel didier
fischer ali et bousselham pour la
municipale partielle le second tour de
cette municipale partielle
le troisième candidat david pelletier
ancien membre de la majorité a indiqué
ce mardi qu'il se retirait du scrutin sa
liste sans étiquette agir ensemble pour
coignières était arrivé en troisième
position du premier tour avec 15 points
59 % des suffrages et david pelletier
qui ne donne aucun
une consigne de vote pour rappel les
deux listes restantes se déclare
également sans étiquette celle de didier
fischer qui est en ballottage favorable
face à la liste dali bousselham mardi 27
novembre journée nationale de la
générosité aujourd'hui c'est aussi le
début de la 34ème campagne d'hiver des
restos du coeur quinze mille
bénéficiaires vont se rendre dans les 27
centres des yvelines marianne iapichino
a suivi cette première journée au centre
de trappes regarder les bras chargés et
le sourire aux lèvres les bénévoles du
centre des restos du coeur de trappes
s'affairent aujourd'hui s'ouvre la
campagne d'hiver tout doit être prêt
pour la première distribution de l'après
midi aujourd'hui on est reparti voilà
donc il va y avoir les gens qui sont
venus s'inscrire la semaine dernière et
puis des tas de familles qui sont pas
venus et qui vont venir en corse après
midi donc ça va être chargé le centre
est ouvert trois jours par semaine les
lundi mardi et jeudi
la matinée consacrée à la réception des
produits récoltés dans les grandes
surfaces
il faut ensuite les trier et les mettre
en place un travail qui nécessite de la
main d'oeuvre
nous avons des compléments du complément
donc ça peut être des gâteaux que ces
dames sont en train de préparer donc ll
trier les paquets et elle prépare pour
faire des petits sachets pour que chaque
personne accueillie plus avoir un petit
peu de gâteaux d'accord justement
drilles au national a elle même
bénéficiaire est venu prêter main forte
après une visite et une explication du
fonctionnement des lieux la jeune
albanaise arrivé en france il ya quatre
ans est rapidement mis à contribution
voilà donc un peu le centre ben écoute
je te souhaite la bienvenue et merci de
le proposer de nous aider voilà tout 400
en famille qu'ils soient accueillis
voilà donc c'est vraiment très important
d'essayer d'avoir des gens qui viennent
nous aider même que ce soit une matinée
une après midi
voilà chaque bénévole est bienvenu chez
nous l'après-midi le local prêté par la
municipalité sur mon plis sabrina
bertrand vit seule avec trois enfants
elle vient chaque semaine il connaît
bien l'équipe trappistes des restos pour
moi c'est comme une famille où deux
familles sont bien comme ça m'évite de
rester tout seul isolé comme chaque
bénéficiaire à la temps d'être appelé
par un bénévole avec lequel elle va
remplir son caddie en fonction du nombre
de personnes dans le foyer elle a droit
un certain
nombre de points des points à dépenser
pour chaque famille de produits des
légumes jusqu'à la viande en passant par
les produits laitiers au total chaque
bénéficiaire repart avec un repas par
jour et par personne
six jours par semaine au revoir et en ce
lancement de la 34ème campagne d'hiver
des restos du coeur ils ont besoin de
bénévoles des restos du coeur n'hésitez
pas à rejoindre l'association ou bien à
lui faire un don à trappes toujours un
rassemblement de parents d'élèves hier
lundi devant l'école jean macé
mobilisation à l'initiative notamment de
la fcpe pour un père de famille algérien
a menacé d'expulsion de territoire son
enfant est scolarisé dans
l'établissement la procédure qui devrait
intervenir au plus tard le 3 décembre et
dénoncé par la fcpe qui met en avant la
volonté de la famille de s'intégrer une
pétition envoyée à la préfecture des
yvelines a déjà recueilli plus de 150
signatures dans deux semaines c'est le
téléthon le marathon du don pour la
recherche contre les maladies rares en
france trois millions de personnes sont
concernées par ces pathologies est les 7
et 8 décembre 30 heures de collecte vont
financé à 85% le généthon c'est un
laboratoire leader de la thérapie
génétique des maladies rares mélanie
poké et patrick jacques de dixmude se
sont rendus dans les locaux dans ses
locaux situés à evry en essonne elle la
recherche continue pour améliorer le
quotidien des malades depuis 28 ans
maintenant le généthon travail sur les
maladies rares 80% de ces maladies ont
une origine génétique
le généthon est basé à evry en essonne
et à quelques jours de la 32e édition
l'afm téléthon nous a ouvert les portes
de ses laboratoires
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
avancées
[Musique]
j'ai été pionnier parce qu'il a été un
des tout premiers laboratoires à
s'intéresser à la thérapie génique qui
est vraiment là proche de choix pour
traiter les maladies génétiques des
maladies génétiques rares
pour vous est atteint d'une maladie
génétique ça veut dire que certains
gènes dans vos organes malades
présentent des mutations
nous ce qu'on va essayer de faire c'est
de remplacer ce gène malade par une
version normale du gène
aujourd'hui nous avons huit produits
sont de notre recherche qui sont en
cours d'expérimentation clinique sévères
sont des des produits qui aujourd'hui
sont injectés à des à des malades et
dans des chants variés puisque nous
avons des produits pour les myopathies
maladies du muscle des produits pour des
immunodéficiences maladies du système
unitaire pour des maladies du sang grâce
à vous des maladies ont été vaincus mais
d'autres restent à vaincre pour avancer
sur les chemins du médicament très
clairement nous sommes entourés
d'experts notamment d'un conseil
scientifique nous sommes entourés aussi
de scientifiques qui sont dans nos
laboratoires et tous les ans avec les
fonds du téléthon financent à peu près
900 à 1000 chercheurs
concrètement aujourd'hui c'est alors si
j'avais à donner à peu près un chiffre
qui soit assez illustratif c'est 5 % des
maladies rares alors sachant que les
maladies rares elles sont au nombre de
sept mille donc 5 % des maladies rares
pour lesquels aujourd'hui il y as soit
des traitements qui sont arrivés ou qui
vont arriver pas tous en thérapie
génique à ça veut dire qu'on doit pas
oublier les 95% les maladies rares pour
lesquels n'y a pas de traitement elle
les avancées concernent notamment deux
maladies la myopathie myotubulaire qui
touche un garçon nouveau-né sur
cinquante mille et dont la moitié décède
avant l'âge de 18 mois
il s'agit d'une maladie dans les
mutations sont localisés dans un gène
qui est qui est localisé sur le
chromosome x donc en fait sien ce une
maladie qui se manifeste principalement
chez les garçons
de la naissance avec donc une faiblesse
musculaire généralisée c'est hier que
tout le corps vraiment du mal à bouger
même à respirer donc la plupart de ces
enfants décèdent dus à une insuffisance
respiratoire et on sait que le pronostic
est très sévère bc clinique a démarré il
ya un an ou en 2017
il s'agit d'un essai clinique
international qui a commencé aux états
unis et qui qui donne des résultats
assez prometteur pour l'instant et le
syndrome de krieger najjar un cas sur un
million de naissances environ la maladie
touche le foie dans son corps elle
accumule un composé toxique en appel la
bilirubine qui est un pigment biliaire
qui a une couleur jaune et qui donc
provoque chez elle une jaunisse la
bilirubine est un composé toxique qui
peut atteindre le cerveau et provoqué
des dommages neurotoxiques et qui peut
aller même jusqu'à la mort on estime que
même une restauration de 5% du taux
normal de danse gym qui est manquante
celle écrite leur najjar pourrait
suffire à traiter la maladie
donc ça c'est vraiment important parce
qu'on sait que la thérapie génique ne va
pas avoir un effet à 100% mais on sait
que c'est pas la peine de traiter
complètement le fois un petit un petit
pourcentage sera ce sera suffisant en
2016 écrit y pose kenzy qui produit les
médicaments pensé par le généthon en
2005 est lancé item ou travaillent huit
équipes
c'est un institut qui travaille sur les
cellules souches et qui permet en fait
d'étudier les maladies génétiques rares
donc et maladies monogéniques et en fin
de compte nous on va travailler donc
avec cet outil qu'est important donc les
cellules souches et on va regarder les
différentes applications possibles
autour de ce modèle c'est une approche
différente en termes de stratégie
puisque le jeune et on va avoir une
approche sur la thérapie génique et nous
notre axe thérapeutique en fait se situe
plutôt sur la thérapie cellulaire donc à
partir des cellules souches et on va
également fait modéliser des pathologies
grâce à ses cellules
on
la prochaine édition du marathon du don
c'est les 7 et 8 décembre le parrain
cette année c'est le chanteur pascal
obispo est toujours qu'elle chiffre à
composer pour donner le 36 37 en 2017
l'afm téléthon avait récolté plus de 2
89 millions d'euros et de nombreuses
communes des yvelines se mobiliseront à
l'occasion de ce téléthon c'est le cas à
coignières ou des animations se
tiendront le samedi 8 et le dimanche 9
décembre trois invités en plateau avec
moi pour en parler khadija beers et
christine amis et julien collenot
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors
vous êtes les co organisateurs de ce
téléthon à coignières vous êtes quatre
au total organisateurs alors on parle
presse de premier téléthon à cognin
parce que ça parce que ça faisait
nombreuses années qui avait pas une
opération globale du téléthon à
coignières voilà donc sur la commune en
fait on a eu des des petites actions qui
étaient menés par par des commerçants ou
des responsables d'hôtels
là on a décidé de faire le
le téléthon cette année ensemble au
début ils devaient être réalisés avec la
commune avec le conseil municipal des
enfants et avec la situation politique
actuelle ce projet était suspendu
donc on s'est réunis tous les quatre
pour mettre en place une grosse
manifestation sur la commune et pouvoir
faire entrer toutes les générations dans
cette journée des situations politiques
vous en parler ce deuxième tour des
élections municipales qui se tient
partiale qui se tient ce dimanche
petit tour de table on va rester avec
vous julien collenot pourquoi ça vous
tenait à coeur de vous engager dans une
telle action organisée ce téléthon à
coignières alors pour moi les enfants
ils sont beaucoup trop
écarté des problèmes que les autres
enfants peuvent peuvent avoir sur le
handicap tout ça on a beaucoup de
moqueries au niveau des écoles ce qui
arrive assez fréquemment
donc on veut les amener justement à leur
faire prendre en compte qu' il peut y
avoir des enfants différents mais que
ma rue malgré la maladie on peut quand
même travailler ensemble et faire un
bout de chemin dans la vie à l'école et
après tu es déjà bien pourquoi vous êtes
vous engagé dans cette action alors il
ya une trentaine d'années moi lorsque je
devenue éducatrice spécialisée j'ai
travaillé auprès d'enfants atteints de
la myopathie
j'ai vu les dégâts j'ai vu évidemment la
souffrance à la fois de l'enfant et la
famille de la fratrie
donc c'est vraiment un projet qui me
tenait à coeur depuis pas mal d'années
et je suis ravi de pouvoir être soutenu
dans ce projet là on termine ce tour de
table avec vous christine l'ami pardon
j'avais perdu votre nom du coup pourquoi
vous ça vous tenez à coeur de vous
engager projet téléthon un peu tout ça
de toute façon c'est effectivement pour
que les gens vivent ensemble sache vivre
ensemble malgré tous les handicaps
pouvoir aider aussi une grande cause
fédérer dans notre ville autour de
quelque chose de
justement et donc pour le handicap c'est
quand même autour de la myopathie c'est
quand même le seul pour le moment qui
est vraiment enfin le pouvoir de fédérer
autant je pense
et comme nous on est quand même des
petits joueurs on n'a pas voilà c'est là
deux premières grandes organisations
fallait quelque chose de grand aussi
c'était voilà c'était nécessaire qui est
de nouveau cette grande organisation
cette grande journée deux grandes
journées de mobilisation pour le
téléthon à quoi nous nous sommes trois
en fait nous sommes quatre avec isabelle
monthermé qui n'a pas pu venir
aujourd'hui qui est laid de formation
assistante sociale qui est aussi
évidemment touchés par ce problème pour
avoir rencontré des gens touchés par
cette pathologie
voilà nous sommes vraiment très très
intéressé pour faire bouger tout ça pour
pour que les gens soient le plus au
courant de tout ce qui peut se passer et
surtout que tout le monde puisse
participer et lever les fonds évidemment
pour la recherche
pour aller plus loin avec les derniers
rebondissements politiques à coignières
du coup c'est ce que ça a été difficile
de l'organiser ce téléthon ce qui a eu
des difficultés
il ya eu un petit peu de difficultés
mais on a quand même réussi à s'en
sortir on a on a eu de nombreux
bénévoles sur la commune et dans les
communes alentours qui ont été très
solidaires qui nous on l'a jamais lâché
qui ont pris aussi le relais parce qu'on
a été assez déportés pour gérer cette
manifestation
franchement on a une brown solidarité
qui s'est créée dès la première réunion
d'information les remercie du fond du
coeur parce qu'ils ont été vraiment
présent et partant et ça continue
voilà donc en fils commence à
s'organiser sans te faire revenir un
gros téléthon à coignières comment
contacter les partenaires voilà comment
ça s'est déroulé
facebook merci tous les messages
exactement utiliser des outils
numériques des réunions des réunions
régulières où tout le monde est présent
avec une belle énergie
en tout cas tout le monde veut y
participer il ya une bourse de noël tout
récemment les parents d'élèves qui l'ont
mis sur pied ont participé à leur
manière pour qu'il y ait des fonds
collectés déjà à ce moment là et merci
encore à la main sur on sur le programme
il ya trois lieux ce téléthon se
déroulera sur trois lieux
le gymnase du moulin à vent la piste de
course si le stade de football
si on fait un petit point sur le
programme alors on aura peut-être temps
de tout détailler mais l'église le
samedi le dimanche par donges a déjà son
programme du samedi qu'elle est il ce
programme alors ça c'est une grosse
journée de 9h jusqu'à 16h30
on fait de la zumba ont fait de
l'échauffement musique pour le tournoi
de foot ont fait de la sensibilisation
au handicap en étant dans un fauteuil
roulant ont fait la course en joëlette
ont fait la course du muscle on fait du
tir à l'arc plein d'activités qui sont
liées au tour du sport pour justement
pouvoir travailler entre personnes
handicapées et personnes
il essaie de se dépasser y aura du défi
proposé au coni rien c'est ça ici et en
parlant des filles on a ce fameux défi
guirlandes que nous proposons
à toul et toutes les personnes qui
seront présentes y compris les écoles
puisque julien est allé en parler aux
élèves
c'est une guirlande qui partira donc du
gymnase jusque jusqu'à l'église par
impasse du marché j'aurai le marché de
noël ce jour là qui fera on a compté 1
800 m 800 m donc voilà une guirlande qui
sera faite de petits fanions alors sous
forme de tissu enfin tous supports
possibles des dessins les messages
les enfants pourront agrafé où nous et
sur cette pierre landes qu'on déroulera
à la fin de cette journée
en espoirs en lait jusqu'au bout et y
avoir un temps clément
surtout j'en parlais un tournoi de
football aussi sur ses lourds mais
seulement c'est un tournoi de football
co organisé par le club de foot
justement de coignières donc elle que
les dirigeants les entraîneurs dont qui
vont créer un tournoi intergénérationnel
donc des plus jeunes jusqu'aux plus âgés
on essaie de mélanger les
les tranches d'âge dans les équipes et
justement fédérer ce lien entre toutes
générations pour la luttre pour le
téléthon en fait des boutiquiers
christine l'ami ça se terminera le
dimanche avec un concert n'ira un cancer
qui sera donné dans l'église st
un oxer de coignières ce sera à peu près
d'une heure je pense enfin c'est ce
qu'ils savent à peu près prévu ce sera
un contest concert avec des
trompettistes et puis aussi avec de
l'orgue du des instruments à vent
différents voilà sur le principe pour
participer on achète un ticket un ticket
c'est un euro c'est ça pour l'instant on
part sur un ticket pour un euro après
c'est le don au chapeau comme on dit
donc les gens donnent ce qu'ils ont
envie pour faire un don au téléthon il
d'alertés sur les ambitions pour ce
premier téléthon est en tout cas le
téléthon qui revient à coignières
qu'elles sont telles qu'elles sont vos
les objectifs que vous vous êtes fixé
elle est d'abord d'avoir beaucoup de
bénévoles bien sûr parce que l'actuel
mans on est un peu en manque de
bénévoles pour faire différentes choses
il faut enfin pour faire toutes ces
activités là il faut pouvoir gérer
les postes sont plein de points les
buvettes parce qu'on a réussi à avoir
beaucoup de partenaires qui nous
permette de pouvoir avoir des buvettes
et des points pour pouvoir manger
et puis il va y avoir besoin de gens
pour faire de la sécurité des gens pour
gérer tous les postes donc plus nous
aurons de bénévoles
au mieux on sera sera heureux l'appel
est lancé merci à vous trois qui a déjà
bien christine amis et merzhin un
colloque organisateurs de ce téléthon à
coignières rendez vous le samedi à huy à
décembre de 9h à 16h30 et le dimanche 9
décembre à 17 heures vous pouvez d'ores
et déjà faire un don au téléthon sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
encore un mot de solidarité cette fois
ci entre les différentes générations la
première pierre symbolique d'un
programme immobilier qu'aucun âge a été
posée à guyancourt il s'agit d'une des
toutes premières résidences
intergénérationnelles en france des
jeunes actifs mais aussi des retraités
vont y cohabitent et se rencontrer lé
précision de manon varaldo à l'angle du
boulevard du château et de la rue
jacques prévert de guyancourt des
travaux de taille sont en cours
jeudi 22 novembre la ville réciprocité
france habitation et eiffage sont venus
pour la pose de la première pierre de la
résidence sociale coucou nages qui
englobera toutes les générations
c'est plus qu'important pour un groupe
comme eiffage immobilier puisque cette
première pierre c'est la première
résidence intergénérationnelle
baptisé qu'aucun âge que nous réalisons
en ile de france c'est un moment
particulier puisque c'est un travail de
trois ans d'études et de préparation
que nos convoitises ont aujourd'hui à
guyancourt au rez-de-chaussée de cette
résidence se trouvera une maison des
projets qui permettra à tous de
développer une vie commune c'est aussi
une alternative au logement traditionnel
inadaptée au vieillissement et aux
maisons de retraite dédiée aux personnes
âgées dépendantes
ce qui est important dans ce type de
projet c'est que l'on arrive à mixer les
générations parce que les personnes qui
sont en perte d'autonomie pour qu'elle
puisse garder avait un lien social et
donc le fait de pouvoir mettre en un
même endroit des jeunes et des moins
jeunes des gens en pleine autonomie et
en perte d'autonomie
c'est finalement l'avenir puisque on
crée du lien social la résidence cooke
où nagent proposera 84 logements à
vocation sociale et s'inscrit dans un
projet de la ville
on va terminer avec la coulée verte qui
fera le lien entre les quartiers
et puis la fin de l'aménagement de deux
du boulevard du château et de la place
du marché aussi et là on aura quelque
chose qui va faire en sorte que ce
quartier du pont du rotois re on ait pu
redonner une nouvelle image à ce
quartier la livraison de la résidence
cooke ou nage de guyancourt est prévue
pour juillet 2019 avec moi sur ce
plateau mélanie poquet bonsoir en sari
cinéma vous venez tous les jours sur ce
plateau alors après l'environnement le
sport et la musique c'est l'espace qui
est à l'honneur cette année le festival
saint quentin le fil le festival du film
documentaire de notre chaîne tv 78
revient pour sa quatrième édition
mélanie pots cassés votre coup de coeur
de la semaine
tel est le programme la première la
première date à noter dans vos agendas
c'est la soirée d'ouverture elle se
passe à gc skywest à partir de 19h30 ce
soir la sarre enregistrait une édition
spéciale du peuple émission de patrice
carmouze
il aura autour de lui quatre invités
donc deux chercheuses lune du latmos
l'autre du cnrs l'entrée est gratuite il
faut juste s'inscrire sur le site du
festival
3w 50-1 point fr on rappelle cet
important c'est avant tout un festival
du film documentaire
et oui cette année huit films sont en
compétition grégory huit documentaires
qui vont vous emmener la tête dans les
étoiles vous découvrirez des projet
d'observatoire toujours plus grand pour
être servi les étoiles la formation des
futurs grands pilotes français est bien
sûr une aventure qui a passionné des
milliers de personnes le voyage de
thomas pesquet le dernier spationaute
français avoir été dans l'espace et un
objectif de montrer que ce qui vient de
l'espace nous touchent au quotidien
beaucoup des progrès scientifiques la
téléphonie mobile les travaux sur les
small size par exemple sont directement
dérivés y compris des travaux d'apollo
de l'époque
est ce qu'il faut dire c'est ce choix du
thème de l'espace n'est pas anodin pour
saint quentin en yvelines
savez-vous pas mais sur le territoire
des yvelines de l'agglomération ont
juste très régulièrement les étoiles de
grands entreprises travaillent dans cet
univers airbus thales
sow mais aussi des laboratoires il nous
semblait logique de travailler sur cet
espace qui bien génère beaucoup beaucoup
d'emplois sur le bassin de 50 en ville
ça c'est pour la partie j'allais dire
purement économique mais également on
est tous des petits garçons et petites
filles qui avons dès notre plus jeune
âge lever les yeux pour regarder les
avions ont levé les yeux pour regarder
les fusées et donc ça parle au grand
public sa part à nous tous alors à
l'issue plusieurs prix vont être remis
le prix tv 78 celui de troisième sylvie
des cinémas et les spectateurs auront
aussi leur mot à dire avec le prix du
public
en plus des documentaires des films sont
aussi diffusées chez les cinémas
partenaires du célèbre stanley kubrick
2001 l'odyssée de l'espace au tout
dernier damien chazelle forsman qui
parle de neil armstrong
laissez vous tenter grégory laissez vous
rêvez il ya de quoi effectivement et à
l'occasion de la soirée d'ouverture de
ce festival saint quentin tv 78
délocalise son plateau à l'ugc de
skywest demain 18 heures retrouvez nous
en direct depuis le centre commercial
saint quentinois pour un 7 8 journal
spécial où nous parlerons largement de
l'événement à partir de 19h30 patrice
carmouze prend le relais avec ses
invités pour son émission puff
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans un
instant pour le 7-8 culture c'est dans
un instant après une page de pub et de
bande annonce bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]